in this world
[Music]
Harry Styles serving style at the
Grammys
Harry takes the stage on Sunday
performing his hit track as it was in a
silver Fringe jumpsuit
[Music]
[Applause]
and if that moving stage looks familiar
it's because it's spot on to the one in
his music video
know it's not the same as it was
as it was
we know it's not the same but before he
slayed his performance
[Applause]
[Music]
Harry turned heads on the carpet rocking
a sparkling custom jumpsuit
but he clearly wasn't done he changed
into this to accept the award for best
pop vocal album for Harry's house
proving he was the knights big winner
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much
this album from start to finish has been
the greatest experience of my life
I wouldn't be without you thank you so
much thank you